Next up, the "New York Post" has some interesting results
from a new survey.
They found that among women who admitted to cheating,
the most popular pet that they had,
I don't know why they did this study, but it was a cat.
So if you own a kitty, you're more likely to go on the prowl
is what they're saying.
And also, if you have a fish,
you might be a little slippery,
'cause fish came in second.
Oh, wow.
So all these women with cats
are fe-lying to their partners.
Wow, wow, Ross.
Do you think there's anything there?
Do you think it's just stupid?
I think. (laughs)
I just thought that pun was so intricate.
(Ross laughs)
It was a multisyllabic pun.
Which one, on the prowl?
Yeah, it was on the prowl.
Fe-lying.
And Fe-lying.
Fe-lying, the fe-lying.
Fe-lying was impressive.
The cat, it makes sense to me 'cause it's like,
first of all, cats,
I don't know, they're a little bit of a sociopathic animal.
And like I love cats.
Like we have two cats.
I'm so in love with your cats.
What are their names?
Precious and Mr. Mustache.
I'm guessing Mr. Mustache is the one on the left.
Yeah, you can guess. (laughs)
Mr. Mustache.
I dated a guy named Mr. Mustache once.
(Mike and Drew laughing)
But he didn't realize that was his name.
No, no!
No, no.
No, but cats have this thing,
where I was trying to write a will.
Have you ever written a will?
Oh my gosh.
I have, and I need
to update it.
It's a terrifying thing.
'Cause some of the people I left stuff to,
I gotta change that.
(Everyone laughing)
I just updated mine.
Yeah, yeah.
I was writing a will and it was like, pets.
And I was like, "Pets?"
Like we got our cats at a shelter,
that would be a real rags to riches story.
They pocket that kind of cash
after judging me for all these years.
But my experience with cats
is like they really do judge you,
especially when you're taking a shower.
They're like, "Oh yeah?
You're gonna use that much water?
Really, really?
Yeah, you can do that,
or you could do this.
Done, done!"
Done!
And so eco-friendly!
Yeah, I know.
Just lick yourself!
No water, no water.
(upbeat music)